with allusions to previous mcu movies
and references to comics that haven't
made their way to the big screen
avengers end game reminds marvel fans
that the people behind the camera are
just as enthusiastic as the ones filling
the seats here are some lines in
avengers end game that were more
important than you may have realized if
you saw avengers end game in a packed
theater then the moment thor's hammer
meownia flies into captain america's
hand probably inspired one of the
loudest and most enthusiastic responses
from the audience
[Applause]
if not then it's at least met with
enthusiasm from thor himself who yells i
knew it as he spots cap threatening
thanos with a legendary weapon so what
did thor mean by i knew it in an early
scene in 2015's avengers age of ultron
thor gives the rest of the team
permission to try to lift meonia thor
sits back confident none of his mere
mortal teammates will prove worthy to
wield the hammer until steve rogers
gives it a
[Music]
shot that brief nudge and past comic
book stories in which cap has proven
worthy of meownia left some fans
theorizing that cap could have lifted
the hammer but chose not to in order to
spare his teammate any humiliation
apparently the odin son was one of those
fans when thor yells i knew it he
betrayed that he thought cap was faking
way back in 2015 as well and how
couldn't they perhaps as worthy as they
come speaking of thor and what he may or
may not be worthy to wield the thunder
god initially thinks he's the only one
capable of using the new infinity
gauntlet to bring back everyone thanos
purged in avengers infinity war the team
argues about it and eventually it's the
hulk who convinces everyone he's the
only guy for the job as he does it's
made clear he's thinking about a
conversation he had seven years before
with tony stark in avengers as stark and
bruce banner look for a way to track the
tesseract downey brings up banner's
other guy and compares it to the arc
reactor which at the time was still the
only thing stopping shrapnel and stark's
chest from killing him banner
understands stark's suggestion that the
hulk saved bana's life and the gamma ray
explosion but isn't totally on board
with the idea
it's a nice sentiment
saved it for
what
i guess we'll find out in avengers end
game he finally finds out what he was
saved for explaining that he's the only
one who can wield the stones and that
their radiation is mostly gamma the same
as the radiation that turned him into
the hulk banner says quote it's like i
was made for this when hulk goes back in
time to 2012's battle of new york his
assignment is to retrieve the ayah of
agamotto aka the time stone instead of
doctor strange the hulk finds the
ancient one waiting for him at the
sanctum sanctorum banner and the ancient
one argue over whether or not it makes
sense for her to risk her own timeline
by handing over the stone it's when the
ancient one learns that strange gave the
time stone to thanos that she changes
her mind she tells banner quote strange
is meant to be the best of us as she
gives him the time stone meaning that
she realizes her future student wouldn't
surrender the stone unless there was a
good reason considering what happens in
2016's doctor strange the ancient one's
reaction is interesting four years from
when she calls him the best of us she'll
have strange physically thrown out of
karmatage
teach me
no
you could call this a contradiction but
it could also suggest a lot more
complexity to the early sorcerer supreme
and her decisions did she expect strange
to eventually show up and wrestle with a
decision or whether or not to let him in
or perhaps a sensing mordo's potential
for turning on his allies did she kick
strange out just to see what mordo's
reaction would be shortly after tony
stark figures out time travel he settles
down on a couch with pepper and talks
about what he should do next he tells
her that part of him wants to scrap all
his work box it up and drop it to the
bottom of the lake this is the same
pepper who almost left tony's employ in
2008's iron man over his armored
adventures and who was ready to break up
with him over his constant tinkering in
2013's iron man 3. this is a new level
of lame she clearly developed a sense of
resigned acceptance since we last saw
her because her words seemed to be what
convinced tony to take his new
innovation to the avengers after
listening to her husband peppa tells him
that trying to stop him has been one of
the few great failures in her life it's
accurate as anyone who has seen all the
iron man entries can testify but there's
a bittersweet irony you don't see until
the end of the movie's climactic battle
after tony uses the infinity stones to
wipe out thanos and his forces he
collapses and struggles to hold on to
what little life he has left peppa wills
herself to smile at her dying husband
and tells him quote you can rest now and
so he does finally and tragically peppa
gets tony to stop when captain america
proves himself worthy of meownia it
isn't the only time in the final battle
that the old soldier has fans clapping
and cheering after the heroes thanos
perch and avengers infinity war finally
appear along with the forces of wakanda
karmatage and new asgard cap takes his
place at the head of this army of
resurrected friends he leads the charge
against thanos's dark forces with the
line comic book fans have read so often
avengers assemble you may not even
realize it until that moment but we've
been waiting for over 10 years to hear
caps say it he may have led the team in
2012's avengers but he never said the
line he even teased us with it at the
close of avengers age of ultron
avengers
when the cap finally says the line in
end game if you hadn't realized it
before it suddenly occurs to you that
the mcu architects waited a long time
for that line and man was it worth the
wait it's emma fer men playing scott
lang's daughter cassie in avengers ends
game not the younger abbey ryder fortson
who plays renatman and ant-man on the
wasp but that doesn't stop scott from
recognizing her when he returns from the
quantum realm at the end of the reunion
scene scott says you're so big it seems
fairly obvious and it's something adults
say to kids all the time if they haven't
seen them for a bit you're so big and so
well grown but it has a double meaning
understood by fans of the comics in 2004
the comic book version of scott lang was
seemingly one of the fatal victims of
marvel's avengers disassembled event in
the wake of his death his daughter
becomes the hero stature as part of
young avengers like her father she has
powers that can make her smaller or
bigger in a tragic twist stature dies
just after her father is brought back to
life in 2010's avengers the children's
crusade thankfully cassie rejoins the
land of the living and is reunited with
her father in 2015's avengers world
issue 16 because you know she's a marvel
comics character so it's pretty much
mandatory after thanos unleashes his
assault on the avengers compound hawkeye
is the first to get his hands on the new
infinity gauntlet he holds onto the
thing for a while fighting off a swarm
of outriders and surviving an attempt to
steal it by the 2014 version of nebula
but once the purged heroes return and
things get real hawkeye calls for help
the first hero to respond is black
panther who calls out clint give it to
me it's not a particularly memorable
line until you remember how these
characters met and the fact that they
only exchanged two lines of dialogue
before endgame in particular their
entire conversation was about hawkeye's
real name and how little it mattered so
it's kind of funny that's the name black
panther uses an endgame in 2016's
captain america civil war during the
airport battle and shortly after ant-man
shocks the other heroes by turning giant
instead of tiny t'challa advances on
hawkeye the conversation that follows is
short and to the point we haven't met
yet
[Music]
i'm glad i don't care apparently he
started caring just a little bit more by
the time end game rolled around one of
the best action sequences in 2014's
captain america the winter soldier is a
tense and eventually violent elevator
scene as shield operatives who are
actually hydra agents slowly fill an
elevator steve rogers is taking and the
old soldier soon realizes it's walked
into a death trap avengers end game
gives fans a scene acting as both sequel
and prequel as it takes place moments
after loki's capture in 2012's avengers
shield agents are transporting loki's
scepter when the captain america from
the future intercepts them in the
elevator he's able to convince them to
hand over the scepter when he whispers
hail hydra the line references the
marvel comic storyline that introduced a
version of captain america who was
secretly serving hydra this was
extremely controversial and captain
america steve rogers writer nick spencer
received death threats over it hydra cap
is eventually defeated at the end of the
2017 linewide event secret empire ends
game also echoes that series when
shortly after getting the scepter
captain america 2019 is forced to fight
his double from 2012 just as the real
steve rogers defeated his hydra
counterpart in secret empire there are a
lot of sad moments in avengers and games
resolution but one of the funniest
involves thor and the guardians of the
galaxy boarding the benatar with a heavy
sack thor treats the space faring
through his old friends he slaps
star-lord on the back and says as
guardians of the galaxy back together
again thor's reference to as guardians
of the galaxy as more than silly
wordplay in 2018 marvel premiered the
comic as guardians of the galaxy
featuring asgardian characters on a
space quest the most recognizable
characters to mcu fans would be scourge
the executioner played by carl urban in
thor ragnarok and a younger version of
loki who begins the series hidden in the
destroyer's armor there's also valkyrie
throgg the frog of thunder and the thor
like earth hero thunderstrike
considering that as guardians of the
galaxy premiered in the second half of
2018 thor's line actually brings up a
chicken and egg question of exactly who
is referencing whom depending on exactly
when the scene was filmed is still
referencing the comic in that scene or
was he as guardians of the galaxy comic
inspired by that line from the script
shortly after we see cap leading his
support group he visits black widow at
the avengers compound he talks with his
old friend about moving on from the
purge telling her
i keep telling everybody they should
move on
some do
the manners caps talking about accepting
the losses he and that have suffered
rather than trying to find a way to
reverse them but there's a bittersweet
foreshadowing to the line as the movie
continues by the time the credits roll a
captain america and black widow are two
characters who have definitely moved on
black widow sacrifices herself to get
the soul stone from formia while steve
rogers uses his quest to return the
infinity stones to recapture the life he
lost when he plunged into the ice in
captain america the first avenger if you
weren't already crying that reveal most
likely triggered a few happy tears
taste the happy michael
taste it
tastes kind of like sad
check out one of our nearest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about avengers end game are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]